we won't be fooled again that's the
focus of tonight's angle
now there was a lot of speculation
swirling among media types and political
junkies about why joe biden didn't
deliver a live address at one of the 911
memorial sites on saturday's anniversary
conservatives snickered that it was
because biden's handlers worried that
he'd embarrass himself and
liberals blamed it on the possibility
that biden actually might be booed while
speaking they didn't want to have that
but i have another theory that's just as
plausible
why would biden need to speak at all
when george w bush would do it for him
we have seen growing evidence
that the dangers to our country can come
not only across borders
but from violence that gathers within
there is little cultural overlap between
violent extremists abroad and violent
extremists at home
but then there's disdainful pluralism
in their disregard for human life
in their determination to defile
national symbols
they are children of the same foul
spirit
and it is our continuing duty to
confront them
of course bush isn't talking about
confronting the foul spirit of antifa or
blm
remember their rampages and riots cause
death and destruction coast to coast
so do you remember president bush
speaking out about any of that
when they scream that america is
inherently racist
did he ever raise an objection and say
no it's not
when they tried to burn down st john's
church across from the white house
did president bush decry the defiling of
that national symbol no and no
whoever wrote those remarks for bush
this weekend and of course they were
written for him also in effect wrote
them for biden and former presidents
obama and clinton as well
on the 20th anniversary of the 9 11
attacks how cynically clever of the
democrats when biden's on the ropes
to have a former republican president
slash at trump and his supporters
of course the elites who despised bush
for the eight years he was in office
lapped it all up
this
will now be built into his legacy it is
standing up and saying things like that
about truth and about what is real and
what is right and what is factual
children of the same foul spirit is a
striking line
from george w bush this is the biggest
platform george w bush will have for the
year maybe for several years it's clear
he felt like he needed to send a moral
message it also i think lifted people up
in an emotional way also
well bush and obama have coordinated
before in hitting trump
one day in october 2017 both men in
separate speeches
hit trump without mentioning him by name
of course
and when benghazi went down and four
americans died remember bush did not
speak out
when obamacare was rammed through
without a single republican vote
bush did not speak out
when biden created a humanitarian
national security and economic nightmare
at our southern border of course bush
did not speak out
but when donald trump began to slowly
but surely call out and dismantle bush's
globalist legacy
bush couldn't stop himself
then it became personal
bigotry seems emboldened
our politics seems more vulnerable to
conspiracy theories
and outright fabrication
we've seen nationalism distorted into
nativism
we see a fading confidence in the value
of free markets in international trade
we've seen the return of isolationist
sentiments in all these ways
we need to recall and recover our own
identity
how exactly would that be any different
from what any prominent democrat would
have said then about trump
for bush it was only worth speaking out
to defend his own legacy never to stand
up for true conservatism
amidst the avalanche of praise for his
saturday remarks
let's not forget that after seven years
of war the loss of nearly 5 million
manufacturing jobs overseas a little
more than that actually and the 2008
financial crisis
bush's approval rating was in the high
20s at the end of his last full year in
office
republicans under bush lost the house
they lost the senate and john mccain who
doubled down on bush's record got
shellacked by barack obama in 2008.
turns out gop voters had had enough
the country had had enough and now after
they lost their grip on the gop for good
the old bush establishment well they're
older but not wiser
bush's remarks set the stage to boost
biden and the democrats
they're flailing with their agenda now
and poised for a wipeout in 2022 but
bush came in to try to do a temporary
save
and all the media can do all the
democrats can do
is attack republicans as racists white
supremacists and insurrectionists
the entire thing is pathetic
and most of all it's revealing
it shows that they know that their
agenda is delivering despair and will
not improve the lives of average
americans what this fence
it's not just sad it's dangerous that we
are in a situation where we need the
fence it was an incredibly damaging you
know attack on our capital but b the
seeds of that still continue that's the
effectiveness of terrorism that you got
to always be prepared because you don't
know when a
first amendment event with this group
now could turn to a terrorist attack
of course they're talking about this
rally next saturday that no one i know
has ever heard of
their view in bush's view is that since
the republican party is no longer
follows the bushes and the cheneys it
should essentially be labeled as a
terror organization
now this idea is being openly discussed
among the left
let's not kid ourselves the bush has
helped raise 150 million dollars for
jeb's 2016 run
and in the end jib dropped out before
getting to his own home state primary
and they still don't get it
they're not mad at the people who called
him
a war criminal or hitler
who ridiculed him every week on snl the
bushes are mad at the republicans who
rejected their policies
they all claim that trump was the devil
incarnate for demanding loyalty of the
people who work for him
but the truth is the bushes were the
ones who demanded personal loyalty
regardless of how their policies
affected the country
now this is all hard for me to say
actually tonight because i always liked
the bushes personally
but when i questioned and ultimately
helped torpedo bush's nomination of the
supremely unqualified harriet myers to
the supreme court
the bush white house made it clear
they wouldn't ever deal with me again
you see you can never go against the
family
so the old bush guard has declared an
unwinnable war again and this time it's
against the 74 million plus republicans
who voted for trump in 2020 and who
didn't vote for jeb in 2016.
i'm sure they hope that the leftist
historians will i guess treat them more
kindly in the future than they have in
the past maybe they will but i doubt it
so while bush was trying to appeal to
that very media that had demonized him
for years
hmm here's what trump was doing
i'm doing okay huh that's a lot of
meddling
i don't have that many medals i grew up
with you
and you are new york's finest you're
incredible people i love you
well that's kind of what happened to the
gop
it found its real base again
the fact is most conservatives long ago
shook off the allure of the bushes
we found new leaders including exciting
young governors who'll fight for us
instead of against us
and
we won't be fooled again
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else